[Music]
beautiful inspirational and deserved
those are the words that Selena Gomez
used while praising Demi Lovato's
emotional performance at the Grammys
Sunday night I think it was iconic the
rare singer showed nothing but love for
Demi on Instagram saying I wish there
were words to describe how beautiful
inspirational and deserved this moment
was Demi I'm so happy for you thank you
for your courage and bravery is the band
here not yet the longtime friends
starred on Barney before they became
teen Disney stars
[Applause]
[Music]
the two have had their ups and downs but
both are now rising to the top and
returning to the spotlight
[Music]
deme debuted her new track anyone
marking her first time at the Grammys in
three years in her first big performance
since her 2018 overdose
the singer talked to Apple music about
her comeback song it was about a week
after I had been in the hospital and I
was finally like awake and and I just
remember hearing back the songs I had
just recorded and thinking if there's
ever a moment where I get to come back
from this I want to sing this song but
her Grammy performance is just the
beginning the 27 year old is set to sing
the national anthem at next week's Super
Bowl
[Music]